Let's instead go to Ryan from Massachusetts.
Ryan from Massachusetts.
You were on.
Oh, my God.
No way.
You actually paid me.
Well, anyway, I oneman.
I'm a huge fan of the videos, and I just had
a question on the Hunter Biden scandal.
So I wanted your thoughts on that.
If you thought it was just a big hole, Sam,
because I watched some of the interview with
Tucker Carlson.
And one of Biden's hunter Biden's associates
told me I forget his name.
Bobble lines.
It's me.
Yeah.
That's what it was.
So I just wanted your thoughts on that.
If you thought it was like a big scam, just
like how in 2016 with Hillary in Russia, I
know that I want.
I was wondering if you thought it was like
the same thing.
So listen, the I am sure that by mere chance,
there are some assertions that have been made
by Rudy, The New York Post, Baba Linsky, know,
whatever.
I'm sure that there are some aspects and they
could be relatively innocuous that are true
about some of this.
But understand that the story starts with
the idea that we learned about this because
Hunter Biden flew across the country to have
three laptops repaired by a legally blind
guy who despite admitting he didn't actually
see Hunter Biden because legally blind, a
Beau Biden Foundation sticker on the laptop
makes him sure it was Hunter Biden and the
guy when Hunter Biden never picked up the
laptops, he flew across the country to have
repaired up access to the private emails and
then gave them to the FBI.
I mean, you know, it's it's outrageous.
And so I you know, if you say did Hunter Biden,
was he really working with Barrys Maitake?
Okay.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
But it the story they are telling is such
obvious desperation.
Everybody who's tried to corroborate it can't
do it.
It's wacky.
I know.
I was just wondering if you thought, like,
people would actually like believe that and
that can have an effect on the election.
And so there's two questions there.
Do people believe it?
Yes, there are people on the Trump side who
are convinced about it.
Is it going to affect the election?
I really don't think so.
I really don't.
This is an election that is so qualitative
and what's going on?
It's about the pandemic.
It's about the economy.
I don't think this is at all like the Hillary's
email story, which really did get some.
Some, some.
Yeah.
Hold definitely.
Thank you for answering that.
I just meant I forget my other question now.
Well you're from was so good.
You I would go out on top if I were you.
OK, yeah.
Rather than risking an inferior question,
yeah.
All right, I'm going to help you, my friend.
I really appreciate the call and I hope to
hear from you again tonight.
Thank you so much, Jack.
He was going to go and then end up going out
lower and we don't want that.
So I think we're going to keep it going
this way.